This is the blueprint to making your
first million dollars and I'm going to
walk you through it step-by-step even if
you're starting with your first dollar.
So, there's three levels in the
blueprint and level one is fundamentals
and it starts with who you are. And the
reason we start with who you are is
because you are the foundation of
everything that you want to have. And
so, there's a thing of me and the
building blocks of who you are are first
the knowledge that you have, the things
you know about. Second, the skills you
know how to do.
Third, the motivation to actually do
them and fourth, the environment to make
it easy. So, the first pillar of this is
knowledge. In order to become a
millionaire, the first thing we have to
do is know what a millionaire even is to
begin with. A millionaire means that you
have over 1 million dollars in
investable assets liquid
minus your house.
So, your primary residence is actually
excluded from this. Now, I'll give you a
fun fact that you probably don't know.
One out of nine Americans
is a millionaire. And the thing that
separates the people who are the
millionaires from everybody else is what
they know exists. And if you're like,
"Who are you to even say this?" Uh my
name is Alex Hormozi. I own
acquisition.com. Our portfolio of
companies does over 250 million dollars
a year and since 2016 every single
business I've ever started has gone to
over 10 million dollars a year and we
have three companies that are worth over
100 million dollars plus. So, the reason
that rich kids, for example, have an
advantage over poor kids is because rich
kids have parents who tell them about
opportunities that exist that they get
better returns on their time. If you
don't know private equity exists, you
sure as hell aren't going to get into
it. If you don't know that you can
become an investment banker and sell
companies worth hundreds of million
dollars and get percentages of companies
that you didn't even found and take on
no risk, then you're not going to pursue
it. And so, I make these videos so that
you can know things that you might not
naturally have around you or anyone in
your surrounding area who knows that
these things exist. And to give you some
context, I was 22 when I started this
journey and ultimately quit my job
before I ended up starting my first
business. When I did go to quit my job,
I emailed a bunch of different gym
owners cuz I figured I wanted to get
into fitness cuz it was something I was
into. And only one of them got back to
me. And that gym owner was a business
owner. And he was making money. And so,
I moved out to California. I changed my
environment so that I could be around
this guy. And this guy helped me learn
the ropes and taught me about my first
business, which is opening a gym. And it
was only after learning and paying for
consulting for a gym business that I
didn't have that I felt comfortable
enough to begin on my own. So, the
second component of knowing who you are
are the skills you have. These are the
things that you do. And so, what can be
really deceiving about this is people
say, "Hey, I want to be confident. I
want to be charismatic. I want to be
good on camera." But, they make it seem
as though it's a trait. So, a trait
isn't a real thing. What it really is is
a bundle
of
skills.
So, let's say if you wanted to learn the
skill of sales. And so, underneath of
sales, we may have being able to
actively listen, being able to repeat
back what someone says, nodding and
keeping eye contact, being able to shake
a hand firmly, walking into a room and
being able to project your voice, being
able to have reasoned arguments with
someone if they have some fallacy that
they believe that you can help them
overcome. All of these are sub skills
that if someone exhibits all of them,
someone say he's a good salesman. Now,
if you have this first level skill, you
can usually become a millionaire
literally with just that. But, then
fundamentally, if you want to level up
you can learn marketing.
And marketing is basically sales done
one-to-many. And so, all the things that
you learn how to do one-on-one, you
start projecting to large amounts of
people. And so, this is just sales at
scale.
And so, underneath of marketing, you
would also have to understand media, so
like where your communication is
happening. You'd want to understand
headlines, uh because that's going to be
the first line of communication. You'd
probably have to learn something about
web pages, and you'd have to have to
learn conversion, right? These are all
sub skills underneath of marketing that
would make you a good marketer. Now, if
you know sales and marketing, then
you know acquisition, because that means
that you can completely acquire
customers. And so, each of these skills
stacks on top of one another and makes
all of the skills retroactively more
valuable. So, the more you learn, the
better you get, the better you get, the
more you get. And so, the path to
becoming the person who can make the
first million is predicated on the
knowledge you have about the world so
that you pursue the right path to get
the skills within. And so, sure, it's
just as hard to learn how to pack boxes
in a warehouse, probably, as it is to
learn how to do sales. They take about
the same amount of time to learn. This
one just has significantly higher
returns. And so, this is where the
knowledge shows you where to orient your
effort so you get the highest returns
back on the skills you learn. So, now
let's talk about
motivation, my tiny little box of
motivation.
And so, motivation fundamentally comes
from deprivation. It's from what you
don't have that creates the action or
urgency around acting in general. And
so, for example, if I'm sleepy, I'm
motivated to sleep. If I'm hungry, I'm
motivated to eat. And so, right now, if
you're motivated to become a
millionaire, it's because you lack a
million dollars. One of the easiest ways
to become more motivated in money,
rather than physiological stuff like
hunger or sleep, whatever, is to
surround yourself with people who make
significantly more money. Now,
immediately, you're like, "Wait a
second, I don't know anybody who's a
millionaire." Of course you don't. But,
you may be able to create a reference
group that you compare yourself to who
are millionaires. And so, for me, for
example, when I had my job in Baltimore,
which is what I left to become an
entrepreneur and start my first
business,
most people were just like, "This is a
terrible idea. Why would you throw away
your college years? Why would you throw
away this good job that you have that's
steady and stable and looks good on
paper and sounds good at cocktail
parties?" And it was because I hated it.
And at some point, I realized that
basically everyone except for one guy
that I kind of knew, who we talked about
our entrepreneurial dreams together, all
of them thought this was a bad idea. And
so, at some point, this is where high
agency or high self-belief has to become
more important. Your belief about
yourself has to be more important than
what other people say about you. And so,
this is a perfect segue to my second
tiny little box, environment. And so,
think about your environment as friction
or a lubricant on your goals. And so, if
you want to change someone's behavior,
you change their environment. So, let me
give you a really simple example of
this. I can guarantee you that I can get
every single person in a building to
take their clothes off. How can I do
that? I could do that by locking the
doors. That's one change to the
environment. Second, putting them all
together in one room. Second change to
the environment. Third, cranking the
heat until it's 200°. Eventually,
everyone would strip down because it
would be so hot in there. And so, you
are that little rat in the experiment
and you want to create the box around
you that lubricates the activities that
you want to do. And so, fundamentally,
what you want to think about is, how do
I make it as easy as possible to work as
hard as I can? And then, how do I
eliminate everything else that distracts
me from my goals? More specifically, how
do I eliminate everything that distracts
me from doing the stuff that gets me the
skills that takes me towards my goals?
And so, that means that it could be
people, it could be software, it could
be alcohol. If you just simply put this
as your filter thinking, does this
increase or decrease the likelihood that
I hit my goals? Cut out everything that
it the likelihood that it hits your
goals cuz sometimes that's easier to
see. And then all that you'll be left
with is nothing and time and the ability
to learn and act. I've talked about
something that I call the season of no,
which I've entered multiple times in my
career as an entrepreneur, which is
basically where you're not successful
enough to be in the group of friends
that you want to be in, but you want to
have a completely different lifestyle
than the people you're currently with.
And so you basically just have to say no
to everything. And that means that
you're saying no to the social
gatherings because you know none of
those people there have the goals that
you want and none of them understand
what you want to do. It's saying no to
the distractions and no to the
entertainment that you do normally
because you know that that's not going
to increase the likelihood that you hit
your goal. So for me, I gave up fantasy
football. I gave up drinking with the
boys. I gave up going out. I gave up
really just like friend gatherings in
general. And so the only thing that I
did was I worked and then I went home at
5:00 and then I worked from 5:00 to
9:00. And so I'd work 5:00 to 9:00 in
the morning, go to work, work 5:00 to
9:00 again at night. And so I had 8
hours of time that I could work on me
and what I wanted to do next and 5:00 to
9:00 that I or 9:00 to 5:00 that I
worked in the middle of the day, that
was basically how I paid my bills. And
if you're like, wait, there was no time.
Yes, there was no time. I didn't have a
girlfriend. I wasn't going out to the
movies, right? Like it was just 100%
focused on removing everything that
wasn't getting me close to where I
wanted to go. And if you're like, wow,
this makes me a weirdo. Yes.
Yes, it makes you odd. And if you expect
to be normal and achieve odd and outlier
results, good luck. So we've just
covered who you are and you made a
little bit of money.
The next step is figuring out who to
sell to. And I want to make this really
real for you. And so a lot of people
think that you got to to make a million
dollars, you got to sell 10,000 people
something for 100 bucks, right? And that
would be $1 million, right? That's
that's what that equals. But it's way
easier to just sell 100 people something
that cost $10,000.
Which also equals 1 million bucks. And
so, believe me, finding 100 people way
easier than finding 10,000. And so, the
real problem that you're solving is what
do I have that's worth $10,000? Well,
the thing is is they also don't have to
pay you now. This can be split over 4
years, right? Which would then be 2,500
bucks a year.
Which is now $200 per month.
And for you to acquire the 100
customers, you're talking about two
people
per week.
Which is not that hard. And if you're
reaching out to 100 people per day,
then you getting
two out of 700 people to be willing to
spend $200 a month with you, all of a
sudden this million-dollar goal becomes
a lot more real. If you're trying to
figure out who to focus on for these two
people a week that you're selling to,
that's what I'm going to cover right
now. You have three basic circles that I
have identified from all the
entrepreneurs that I've talked to.
Number one is that you help someone who
is like you overcome something that you
overcame in the past. And so, that's
typically some sort of painful thing or
some sort of problem you figured out a
solution to, and then you operationalize
that for other people. The second is
something that you're just very
passionate about. So, it's like you're
really into this thing, and then you
help other people get into that thing,
too.
The third is some sort of professional
skill. And so, that's like, oh, I used
to do accounting or bookkeeping for this
business, or I used to do building
management, or I used to do property
management. Like, whatever it is, you
have some sort of skill that you learned
in the professional marketplace that you
help other people do. And so, all of
those things, those three P's, pain,
passion, profession, are the three
fundamentals that I look at in terms of
trying to pick the who. So, pain,
passion,
profession.
Underneath of this, if you're like,
okay, where do I want to start? The
reason that I like helping fewer people
rather than more people in the
beginning, is because you don't have
money and you don't have resources. And
so, if you're going to start a business,
you might as well start with fewer
people that pay you more because it's
easier to run that business. And so, I
like to use the the old Tesla analogy
here, which is when Tesla started, he
wasn't trying to bring in the Model 3
into mass market.
He started with the Roadster, which was
the most expensive version of the car
because he knew that the fewest amount
would be able to afford it. The other
thing that this does is it actually
positions you at the top of the
marketplace. Then, he moved down market
and created the Model S, which was now a
$120,000 car. Then, he went and got the
Model X. And then, he had the Model 3,
and then he has the the Cybertruck,
which I think is why. Anyways, the point
here is that he basically worked his way
down and went broader and broader and
broader market as he continued to get
resources and be able to redeploy them
into broader and broader parts of the
marketplace.
And so, for you,
you're going to probably pick what pain,
passion, or profession you're going to
go to. You're going to start with the
smallest version of that market that you
can, the most specific, the closest to
who you can help the most. And so, I
will give you this third little piece
here, which is
if you're for some reason split between
two of these, like, "Well, I like this
and I also overcame this thing." Help
the person that you can provide the most
value to. Now, if you're like, "Okay, I
can help this poor person go up by $10,
and I can help this rich person go up by
$100,000." Then, in a real way, that
$100,000 is a representation of how much
value you can provide that person,
meaning go do that one first. Now, once
you've identified, "Okay, I'm going to
start with a niche. I'm going to pick
one of these three P's." Then, you run
them through these filters that I have.
Is that number one, you want them to
have the problem to solve. Now, all of
these things fundamentally are problems,
right? They There's not enough
information about this passion, there's
not enough information this pain, or
there's not enough information about
this professional they want to learn.
But fundamentally all of those are the
problem. So you have to have a problem
that you're trying to solve, and the
people you're trying to sell to need to
have that problem. Number two is they
have to have the money to spend. If they
don't have the money to spend but they
got the problem, then you don't have a
business around it. You got a nonprofit,
which is not the point of this video.
This is about making money.
Underneath of this
problem to solve
you want them to have the urgency
to solve it now. So this can't be
something that they're like, "Oh, that
would be nice." It has to be something
that they want to solve right now, cuz
this will overcome all of the people who
are like, "Ah, I'm going to think about
it." They keep pushing it off. If you
have cancer and somebody has a cancer
treatment, you want it now. Now, on the
money side, you also want them to have
the authority to spend it.
So you want them to be the one, ideally,
who's the principal, who's the one who
makes the decision about the
implementation that you're going to help
them with. And I want to be really
clear. I use these as thought exercises
to help you get started and pick the who
that you're going to serve. But the end
of the day, if I had to boil all of this
down, it just comes down to this one
truth, which is that you want to serve
the person that you can provide the most
value to. I'll tell you that A16Z, Y
Combinator, etc., they have one rule
that they learned in years, which I will
share with you. Is that they now only
invest in founders who already have
experience with the problem. And I
Again, I define problem very broadly
here. That you have overcome this sort
of difficulty and you've lived with the
problem for 5 plus years. If you've
lived with it, then you intimately
understand it, because that means that
you'll also intimately understand the
prospect that you want to sell to. And
so it kind of is like this hack for
already knowing what their thoughts and
dreams are, what the pains that they're
experiencing, how they talk, the words
they use. So it's kind of this big time
warp of saying, "Oh, I already spent the
last years of my life living being me.
If I can sell to people who are just
like me, then I don't need to do 5 years
of studying and figuring this out." And
so for me, I had struggled getting into
shape. That was my problem. I was not
jacked enough.
Uh and so then I spent all my time
learning about it so that I could become
more jacked. So much so that I annoyed
everyone at at work enough that they
were like, "Please quit this and start
something fitness-related." And so for
me, that was the perfect first pick.
Now, I was between SAT prep. And why was
that? Because I had been pretty good at
test prep. I tested pretty well and I'd
gone through a process of improving my
own scores. And I was like, "Oh, I could
probably help other people improve their
scores, too." The other thing that I was
considering was frozen yogurt. Because I
actually really liked fro-yo at the
time. This is before frozen yogurt
boomed. And so actually was a you know,
kudos to young Alex. It was actually not
a terrible time to get into frozen
yogurt. And so fundamentally, it's like
I had two things I was passionate about
or pain. These are really just equal
sides of the same thing, right? It was a
pain and then I became passionate about
it when I solved it. SAT,
fro-yo, gym. And so actually all three
of these were in this pain
passion bucket. And I chose to start the
gym because uh frozen yogurt cost 150
grand to open, which I didn't have. Then
it was really just between SAT prep and
fitness. And I actually started on the
SAT prep path first. And then I was
going to partner with someone. And then
I'll just say it it ended poorly. And
because of that kind of negative
experience and I wasn't emotionally
mature enough, I said, "Fine, I'm not
doing that. Uh I'm just going to do
fitness." So it was kind of like a
process of elimination. I couldn't do
yogurt cuz I didn't have the money. I
felt like I got uh burned on my SAT prep
thing. And so then I just ended up with,
"Well, I guess I'll just do fitness."
And so the only disclaimer that I have
about all of this stuff that I just
covered, so this is my warning, right?
This is my warning call for you, is that
you want to make sure that you're going
to be in a market that's at least flat
or growing. You don't want to get into a
market that's shrinking.
And so if I wanted to get into
retirement homes for old folks, that's a
growing market. That's a good thing. And
so if you had just recently placed your
grandmother and it was a pain process
for you, and then you figured out how to
do it that solution to other people who
are in the exact same position as you.
And it's probably urgent and they have
the money and authority to do it. You
just don't want to get into selling
print newspapers today. So we've covered
who you are, who to sell to, and you've
made a little bit more money.
And now we talk about what to sell. So
there's four elements that I like to
have in every product that I sell.
Number one is that it's unique. And the
reason for that is because I don't want
anyone else to be able to sell it. The
second
is that it's expensive
because expensive stuff makes you more
money per unit. Third is that I want it
to be sticky. I want it to be things
that people don't just buy once, but
keep buying again and again. And the
fourth is I want it to be air. So
unique, expensive, sticky, air, meaning
it's something that doesn't cost me a
lot to deliver. And so this is basically
the relationship of your gross profit.
It means it costs you a penny, you can
sell it for a buck. And people keep
buying it again and again. And no one
else can sell it but me. So let me show
you a product that everyone's heard of
that actually matches all four of these.
Coca-Cola. It's unique in that no one
else knows the recipe for Coca-Cola.
It's expensive relative to how much it
costs. It might cost a few pennies to
put this together. Really probably the
can is the most expensive part of the
product itself. And it's sticky in that
I mean literally if you spill this on
the floor it is sticky. But on top of
that is that when people start drinking
Coke, they don't stop drinking Coke
products for usually their entire lives.
Imagine introducing someone to a product
and then knowing that they would
literally always buy your product,
they'd always go to restaurants and
order what you had. When they go home
they crack up in your thing. When they
eat food, they drink your products.
That's a great business. So these are
all exceptional things for making your
first million dollars. Now if you want
to make a gazillion dollars, then you
want to add something else to this,
which is scale. So if I I need to have
25 clients like I talked about earlier,
then I very much I could just do myself,
give people time, give people service,
give people some skill set and transfer
to them. That's unique cuz no one else
can do it cuz it's just me. I can charge
a lot cuz it's just my time, which is
the cost. And if I'm good, people pay
again and again and again. And so, these
like a normal service business with one
really good person meets all four of
these things. The issue then becomes
scale. And so, what I'll walk you
through is different ways to make any
product more scalable. I think that
people have a massive misunderstanding
about what it even means. So, the first
part is that it's not is something
scalable or not, it's how scalable is
it. So, this is really easy to scale.
And then this is really hard to scale.
And so, one-on-one with you is harder to
scale than let's say me adding another
user on School, the software platform.
And so, everything about scalability has
to do with something called the
incremental cost of adding a customer.
But, all that really means is how much
cost do we have to incur as a business
to bring on one additional customer. The
most scalable businesses bring on an
additional customer costs almost
nothing. Imagine your cell phone
carrier. If another person signs onto
their network of cell phone usage, it
doesn't really cost them much at all to
add the additional user. If another
person comes onto Facebook, it's not
that much. If another person comes onto
School, it's not that much to add the
person. And so, all of these things are
easier to scale. Now, I will tell you
one of the things that's very
interesting about very scalable
businesses is that typically they're
more demand-constrained, meaning it's
harder to get people to buy that stuff.
Whereas, there are some businesses that
are very hard to scale. Think like a
very high service business, so like
accounting for example, is harder to
scale because it's hard to find really
good accountants and be able to maintain
that quality of service at a high level.
Scaling a law firm, really hard cuz it's
all about expertise, which means you
have to get lots of people and it takes
a really long time to get them good
enough, and you always have the risk of
them leaving. And so, oftentimes very
unscalable businesses have partnership
structures so that people come in so
that they feel like partial owners in
that business. But, if you're the
ultimate original owner, it can be
harder for you to scale. Again, there
are massive law firms. It doesn't mean
that it's impossible, it just means that
it's harder. Congrats, you're 1/3 of the
way there. And now, we move on to level
two.
And this
is level two, and we start with
get them to buy. And there's two steps
to this. Step one is they have to find
out about whatever it is that you sell.
And in fact, I wrote an entire book
about this thing in 100 Million Dollar
Leads, which is getting strangers to to
want to buy your stuff. All right, this
is advertising. The second thing that
you do is you get them to buy. So, let's
start with number one, find out. So,
there are eight things
that you can do to let people know about
your stuff. The first four only you can
do, the second four are things that
other people do
on your behalf. These I call the core
four.
These I call the
four
lead getters.
So, these are the only four things that
one person can do to let other people
know about their stuff. So, you've got
warm outreach, which is letting people
who know you know about your stuff. Cold
is letting people who don't know you
know about your stuff.
Then you've got content, which is
letting people who know you one-to-many
know about your stuff. And then you've
got paid ads, which is letting people
who don't know you one-to-many know
about your stuff. These are the only
four things that you can do to let
someone else know, to force them to find
out about whatever it is you have to
sell, because they cannot buy it unless
they know you exist. Now, if you want to
get more leverage, because this is about
becoming a millionaire,
then you can use these four things to
get lead getters. Now, the first type of
lead getter is a customer. This is the
people who you actually get to buy. Now,
they can get they can do the core four
themselves. They can let people they
know one-on-one. They can let strangers
know one-on-one. They can be in ads for
you, or they can make content. That's
when they make a review, or they make a
post talking about how great your stuff
is. That lets more people know about it.
The next is you've got employees.
Employees do the same core four as you
do on your behalf. So, they do warm
outreach. They do cold outbound. They
make ads for you. They make content on
your behalf. The next version of this is
affiliates.
So, affiliates
are businesses that already have your
customers in their business. And so,
let's say I have a gym. If I want to get
more people in my gym, I can make a deal
with a chiropractor, and I can say,
"Hey, I will send you patients when they
ding themselves at my gym. And then when
you have somebody who wants to lose
weight because that's why their back
hurts, you can send them to my gym." So,
that creates a reciprocal relationship
between you and another business. And
every customer they acquire, they can
send to you and vice versa. And the last
is agencies. So, these are other
businesses that specialize, typically,
in one of these. So, you've got content
agencies, you've got paid ads agencies,
you've got outbound agencies. And all of
those, you'd still have to start with
the core four to contact the agency, and
then they would use the core four to
actually advertise. So, these are the
only things any person can do to let
other people know, and these are the
types of people that become the targets
of the core four that can then do it on
your behalf. Now, if you're trying to
get 25 customers, right? Like I talked
about, like you only need 25 people to
pay you $10,000 a year for 4 years to
become a millionaire, okay? So, the
thing that you have, and that's assuming
no taxes, I'm just going to assume this
is international video. Uh
the first thing and the easiest is here
is warm outbound. You just let people
know who already know you that you have
this thing for sale, and that you're
willing to help them. One of the easiest
offers is, "Hey, I'll help you for
free." So, that means I'll put 3 hours
or 5 hours of my time to helping you
achieve some sort of outcome. And at the
end, if you don't mind, I'd love to make
you an offer about what it would look to
work with me for paid for money in the
future. Very simple offer. And the thing
is is when you offer two, three, four,
five hours plus of your time for free, a
lot of people are willing to do that.
And so, fundamentally, just think about
it like five sales calls that you do in
a row, except it's really smooth and
you're just providing value. And that
way, it kind of gets the jitters out for
people who've never sold before. And
when we actually talk about how to
close, I'll cover that in much more
detail. But, this is the easiest way for
people to start. Now, you can pair this
with content because then you let people
know publicly, "Hey, I'm doing this
thing.
Want to hit me up?" In fact, I'll put my
hopefully first post somewhere over
here. This is the first post I ever made
to promote my business. And it was
something called the free training
project. And I'd already worked with
people doing warm outbound for a year at
that point. And I think I had 13-ish
customers, something like that. And then
I published their results and I said,
"Hey, if you guys want to work with me,
I got a few spots open." And that's what
became my first content post to let
people know
so they could find out about my stuff.
Now, over time, I learned how to run
paid ads and do cold outbound, which is
like calls, emails, DMs to strangers to
say, "Hey, can I give you this amazing
offer?" And ads work the same way,
except we call them up, bring them in,
and close them. And if you're starting
out, this can seem like a lot of stuff
to do. You're like, "Oh, I'm going to do
all eight."
Until you get to a million dollars, you
can just do one of these. And if you're
going to do two, do content and warm
outbound. This is the easiest way to
start, it's also the cheapest. Here, you
have to have a really good skill set.
This is also pretty cheap, it's just
harder to do. But, if you're going to do
cold outbound, you might as well start
with warm. Start with people who aren't
strangers and then level up to people
who are strangers. But, these ones are
the least expensive way of getting
customers. This is the most expensive,
but it scales quickly. So, once people
have found out about our stuff, great.
So, now they know, but now we got to get
them to give us money. So, now we got to
get them to buy. When I started my gym,
I hated the idea of sales. I even heard
someone say, "Hey, you're a salesman."
And I was like I was disgusted by the
idea. I was like, "I'm an academic." And
so, then I had to pay rent and clearly
was like, "How do I get these strangers
to give me money?" And immediately
learned sales. Now, over the last 10
plus years, I've done 4,000 plus
consults and it wasn't until I had to
transfer that skill of sales to other
people that I had to create a framework
that was repeatable for other people to
also close. I remember the first time I
went home for Christmas, uh I had an
employee close their first sale without
me and I got teary because I realized it
was the first time that my business
could make money without me. And so,
this is the framework I have, which is
closer. And so, this is an acronym and
it's very simple and it's easy to
remember. And the reason that one
smaller is not because R is less
important, it's because Amazon, Jeffy B,
decided only send us five of the right
ones instead of the sixth. So, the first
of the closer framework is
clarify why the person is there. And so,
fundamentally, the big advantage that we
have as a business is that these
customers have reached out to us. And
so, we need to clarify why they're even
why they even took the time to reach
out. Why did you respond to our ad? Why
did you respond to my email? Why did you
comment on my post? Whatever it is, if
you have an engaged leads, which means
that they've responded in some way, then
they've taken the first step. In
basically every form of advertising,
this exists. And most people aren't cold
calling and then immediately closing.
And so, even in that situation, you
would call them, set an appointment, and
then on the appointment, you would then
say, "Hey, what made you take this
appointment? What made this worth it for
you?" And then what we're doing here is
we're clarifying the problem. That leads
us to the next letter, which is L, which
is label them with the problem. Now,
that may sound similar, but it's
actually very different. So, what we're
doing is when we label, we say, "Huh, so
it sounds like you are here,
you want to get here,
and this is the thing that's getting in
the way. Does that sound about right?"
And so, what we've done is we've said,
"This is your current, this is your
desired." And we've established a gap,
and sometimes an obstacle.
That's a monster. Okay. And what we want
to do is we want to position ourselves
as the sword that can kill the monster
and ultimately get them to their desired
end state.
But we can't sell unless we have a gap.
And that is why C and L are so important
before you get into anything else. So,
for example, you're 200 lb,
you want to be 150, 50 lb is the gap.
The reason that you're struggling is cuz
you don't know how to work out, you
don't know how to eat. Let me see if I
can get a spoon here or fork. There we
go. You don't know how to eat, and you
have no one who's holding you
accountable to making sure that you do
these first two. In a B2B setting, it's
like you're doing 10K a month, and you
want to make 100K a month, and the issue
is that you don't have ads that are
working, or you don't have enough leads
that are coming in. That brings us to
the next thing. Once we've clarified
where they're we've clearly labeled them
with a problem, you're here, you want to
be here, this is the problem, then you
overview past pain. All right, I call
this the pain cycle. So, you overview
past experiences. The reason this is so
important is that pain is what motivates
action. And so, if you think about
motivation in general, it's always from
deprivation, like I said earlier. So,
you being overweight and reminding them
of how overweight they are and the cost
of being overweight this whole time, it
basically further brings them this way.
It expands the gap between where they
are and then what where they want to go.
And the further that gap is, the bigger
the rubber band is. And so, remember,
this is our amount of deprivation, which
is the amount of motivation to get
someone to buy. And so, when we do the
pain cycle, we simply say, "What have
you done before? How did that work out
for you?" And then, the pieces that they
liked, you compare, you associate with
your solution, and the pieces they don't
like, you associate with why it didn't
work and why your solution is different
this time. Once you get to the end of,
"Okay, what did you do? How did that
work for you? Oh, it's different in this
way. Oh, it's similar in this ways. What
else have you tried?" You keep going
through that pain cycle to continue to
poke on that pain button to keep
expanding the gap between where they are
and where they want to go and the
frustration in the present for not
having achieved it. And so, once we've
overviewed the pain, now we sell the
vacation, S. A lot of people, salesmen,
this is when salesmen blab. This is when
salesmen lose the sale. And the reason
they lose the sale is because they just
do this massive monologue, and that
doesn't work. Instead, what you want to
do is come up with what I call a
three-pillar pitch, and each of the
pillars is usually one or two
statements, and then followed by an
analogy or a metaphor. And so, you say,
"Hey, if you want to
create SEO to get more leads, then it's
kind of like" uh and then we basically
make our transition. "It's kind of like
when you get a paycheck and when you
have an investment account. Your
paycheck, you work and you get paid
every single month, but you put a little
bit of that money towards your
investment. Over time, that investment
compounds until eventually it makes you
more than what you make in your active.
And so, SEO kind of works the same way."
Now, realistically, there's really no
similarity to getting traffic to a
website as there is between paychecks
and investment accounts, but it compares
something that people understand with
something that they don't understand so
they can learn. And so, fundamentally,
you should come up with three analogies
that explain each of the pillars of what
differentiates your solution. If I was
selling leads, which I came up with a
script for mortgage brokers, it was the
leads had to be exclusive, they had to
be timely, and they had to be qualified.
And so, you just say, "Okay, have you
ever gotten on the phone with somebody
who doesn't have money and they're just
window browsing? Yeah, it's a pain in
the ass. Totally, right?" And so, it's
like, "Cool." You just give an example,
you give an analogy that explains it. If
it's something easy to understand,
examples. If it's something hard to
understand, metaphor. And the reason I
call it sell the vacation is that you'll
notice that I'm not actually explaining
much about the product at all. And the
main reason is because they care about
themselves, they don't care about our
product. They care about their problems,
not about our product. And the only
reason they care about our product is if
there's a way that they know with high
conviction that's going to get them to
their goal. And so, we want to talk
about Maui. We want to talk about
Hawaii. We want to talk about where
they're going, what it's going to be
like when they're at 150, when what it's
going to be like when they're making
$100,000 a month, not all the steps it's
going to take to get there. We're not
talking about TSA. We're not talking
about taking your shoes off and sitting
next to somebody who stinks and and
getting on the plane and having bad
plane food. Cuz guess what all of that
stuff is.
I just gave you an analogy. And so once
we've done S, we then go to E, which is
explain away their concerns. So at this
point, after you've overviewed the pain,
you say, "Hey, I think I might have
something for you. Would you like to
hear about it?" They say yes, and then
you go to sell the vacation. Once you've
sold the vacation, you ask. You say,
"You ready to get started? Does that
sound good to you?" Any kind of closing
question you want. Fair enough? Great.
Now, if they then say anything but yes,
I want to buy, you then go to E. Explain
away their concerns. And so the way that
you explain away their concerns is that
typically there's three big categories.
So people blame their circumstances for
why they can't do something. They blame
other people for why they can't do
something, or they avoid the decision
altogether, which is basically blaming
themselves. They give their power
elsewhere. And so within that, you
basically have six categories of
questions that fall underneath. So one
is they say they don't have the time.
"I'm too busy right now. Now is not a
good time." The second is they say, "I
don't have the money to do this right
now. This is too expensive. This is
outside of my budget." Number three is
they say, "Somebody else has the
decision-making authority." All right?
The fourth is they say, "I'm not sure
this is right for me." This is a fit
question. All right? Which is really
just means that they have a preference
that isn't aligned or that they believe
isn't aligned with the product that you
sell. "Oh, I have to follow meal plan. I
don't want to count calories." Five is
they blame other people's past
experiences with them. And so this is
one that we overcome with something I
call Bernie twice, but it's other
people's products. And then finally,
they avoid.
This
is a stall. This is sounds similar to
this, but is actually very different.
This is I don't have time. This is give
me time. That covers the explaining away
the concerns. There's a hundred other
closes I'd give you, but those are the
theories behind each of them. Finally,
we have to reinforce the decision. So
now we have somebody who's made the
decision. They've chosen to given us
money, which is amazing. We love them
for that. But, the thing is is that
sometimes people change their minds when
they go away, especially if you're good
at sales. And so, when you have the R,
what we're doing is we're reinforcing
that they made a good call. Now, this
actually begins the handoff to
onboarding. All right, so when you
onboard a new customer, this is what
happens in the first 24-48 hours
post-purchase. And what you want to do
is make as many promises as you can in
that time period
and keep them. So, that they feel And
we're talking like, "Hey, this is what's
going to happen next. In the next 30
minutes, this is going to happen, right?
You're going to get an email. And then
you can click that link, and then this
is going to happen next." And you want
as many of those things that you tell
them to have happen to happen. And from
this, we do something called BAMFAM,
which is book a meeting from a meeting.
And when you do BAMFAM, it means that no
one ever gets uh left in the cracks. No
one falls through. And so, the reason
that a lot of customers cancel is
because you said someone's going to
reach out to them, and they thought it
was going to take 30 minutes. You didn't
set the expectations. It takes 2 days,
and they're like, "You know what? This
isn't for me. I actually I've changed my
mind." Right? Instead, you want to
always have them It's like a baton pass.
It's like sales passes to onboarding,
onboarding one passes to onboarding two,
onboarding two passes to senior
engineer, or the media buyer, or
whatever it is that you do to deliver
results for people. And at that point,
you've kept them through the process,
and you've reinforced, "You know what?
These guys are on top of it. They're
legit." And if you want to make this
extra magic,
what you do is you pass on the notes.
So, you never want a customer to repeat
themselves. And so, the way you do that
is that you take notes on every call.
And so, if you get on a sales call, for
example, and the setter had notes, then
you can start the call being like, "Hey,
I know you talked to Andrew, and you
said this, this, and this, and these are
the problems you're struggling with."
They're like, "Wow, these guys are on
it." And when that goes to onboarding,
and they have their onboarding
conversation with Sarah, and then Sarah
says, "Oh, I know you talked to Andrew,
and you talked to Jeff, and you said
these things." They're like, "Wow, this
business is legit." Very small change,
massive improvement in in of how
satisfied customers will be. And
because this is all about making more
money, the likelihood that they actually
ascend and buy more in the future.
Yeah. And if you're a beginner, you're
the one taking all of these calls, so at
the very least, take your own notes and
remember what you're talking about these
people. And if you have multiple
customers, review the notes before you
get back on the call with them. Close
more deals, make more money, save the
world. We got them to buy, we got our
first customers, we've made a little bit
of money. Now, we get them to buy even
more. So now, we got to get them to buy
more times. And specifically, this is
all
different ways that you can make a
customer worth more money to your
business. And so, the idea is that the
customers or the businesses that make
customers worth the most are the ones
that make the most money, unsurprising.
But there are eight specific ways that
you can do this with literally any
business. So, the first way is that you
can increase the price. So, for this
example, let's say I'm selling gum, all
right? So, I'm selling gum, and what I
can do is instead of charging $5 for
this, I can charge $6. It cost me the
same amount, but I've now made more
money. The second way that I can do this
is I can decrease my costs. All right,
so if this thing was originally $5 and
it cost me a dollar to make, I can buy
more inventory, I can do advances so
that I can get this down to 50 cents.
So, I still make 50 cents more per box.
That's the second way that we make any
product more profitable for us. The
third way we can do this is we can get
them to buy more times.
So, right now, I say, "Hey, you want to
buy my gum? Great." But wouldn't it be
cool if you got on a gum subscription?
So, you get one of these every single
month. The fourth way
is to get them to buy something else
that's new or different. All right? So,
right now, I'm selling you this gum, but
wouldn't it be cool if you got these
Nicorette patches as well? So, wouldn't
these patches go great with your gum? It
doesn't matter what you sell, you can
have burger with fries, you can have an
iPhone case with your iPhone. There's
always something else that pairs or is
complimentary to whatever your core
offer is. And sometimes, you make more
profit on this thing than you do on the
main thing. The fourth thing that you
can do is get people to buy more
quantity. All right? So, this is when
the number goes up. So, currently you're
buying one box. What if you bought three
boxes of gum? And so, the difference
between this and this is this is how
many times they're buying over a period
of time. This is how we're increasing
the quantity all at once. So, this is
think about this as bulk purchases
buying more volume.
The second way that we can do this is
increase quality. So, now we say, "Okay,
how do we sell you a better version of
this?" So, these ones are 2 mg of
nicotine. These ones are 4 mg. So, if I
have a box of the same size, but I sold
you a 4 mg version, then it might be a
higher quality. Or maybe the nicotine in
this one comes from a magic plant in the
Amazon. Either way, we sell a higher
quality version. If I was selling
burgers, instead of selling mystery
meat, you could sell sirloin burgers,
right? If you're selling iPhone cases,
it would go from plastic to Kevlar. It
would go from uh plastic to metal or
wood. We give a higher quality version
of whatever it is that we sell. And if
you're selling services, there's a
zillion ways you can make more valuable,
but it's like you have higher uh quality
representatives who are going to be
answering your thing. You have priority
support. You get answered first. Uh you
have extended hours. So, you get more
times. All of those things are different
versions of higher quality. The next is
that you can do the equal opposite. You
decrease the quantity. You decrease the
number that someone buys. So, instead of
buying
160 pieces, you just buy 20. So, you can
have a downsell. Now, the reason that
this can make you more money is that it
actually makes you more money per person
you talk to, not per customer. And so,
what this is, you make money here when
you take a no and turn it into a yes.
So, it's taking a no a small note
turning into a small yes, and then
later, you have all these other things
to turn it into a big yes.
And then finally, we go from something
that's higher quality to something
that's lower quality.
So, is there a version of your product
that could be the the the discount
version? The economy class version? And
with services, it's literally the equal
opposite. You have junior reps who
answer it. You have extended times. You
don't get calls, you only get chat
support. It's all just thinking, what
are different ways all the components
and features that I have with my
service? Most times, if you have a
service, you just have to You haven't
even defined all the standards you have.
You just need to think through every
single thing. What about speed? What
about quality? About who they're talking
to? What about the medium they're on? Is
it one to many? Is it one-on-one? Is it
recorded? Is it live? Like, all of these
things are factors that make something
more or less valuable. And so, with
physical products, the same idea, except
it's usually going to be the ingredients
and how new it is. This is an older
model. These are all things that
decrease the quality. And so, when
you're looking at this, these are the
eight ways that you can get any customer
to be worth more. And so, if you're a
beginner, you want to know the easiest
one of these to make more money?
Charge more for the exact same thing.
And often times, when you're a beginner,
you want to start low. So, it's okay.
But, what I would recommend doing is
what I call the five
to five to five model. So, basically,
every five you sell, you bump it by 20%.
All right? Very easy. So, if we're at $5
for our gum here, the first five people,
if everyone buys, no problem, we bump it
to $6. So, $5 goes up 20%, it goes to
$6. And if the next five buy, no
problem, then we go up to 720. And we
keep going up by 20%, and you can keep
doing this forever until people stop
buying. And so, then, you just look at
how much gross profit do I have times
the conversion rate, and that gives you
your perfect price. And so, I'm telling
you, you might be worried about what if
What if I sell fewer people? You just
have to do the math. And you never
discount in order to make a sale. You
can choose to test your price, but you
have to stick with it for the number
that you said you would. The second
easiest one of these to do, besides
obviously raising the prices over time,
is just getting people to buy more
stuff. This one requires nothing new
from you. This one also requires nothing
new. You're just asking them to buy
again next month. This one gets them to
buy more today. And so, these ones are
among the easiest that you can do as a
beginner. This one, decreasing costs,
super valuable for you. Usually takes
more time for you to negotiate with
vendors, get economies of scale, things
like that, but still valuable. All these
other things are things that you add to
the business, which creates more
products. Not saying there's anything
wrong with that, but it's typically a
more advanced move. So, these three
right here are the ones that you want to
focus on if you're a beginner. And this
is a concept that you should understand
how to master. This is the language of
business. And so, it doesn't matter what
we're talking about, you should be able
to apply all eight of these to anything.
So, if I'm selling whiteboards, I say,
"Okay, I can raise the price of this
whiteboard." Next is I can get people to
buy more whiteboards over an extended
period of time. Wasn't that one great?
Wouldn't it be great if you had more of
those for your team? Or I can get them
to buy five whiteboards today, one for
every room in their office, right? Or I
could say, "Hey, this is a, you know, a
flimsy metal whiteboard. Let me get you
a wood one, it'll look better on
camera." Or I can make it higher quality
by saying, "Hey, I won't put my logo on
yours, so that it's not in all your
camera shots."
The next is I can decrease how much it
costs me to actually manufacture each of
these whiteboards. This also increases
my profit. The next thing is I say,
"Okay, you got these whiteboards, but
what about your paper?" Right? That You
know what would go great with your
whiteboard? Rolls of paper. The next is,
"Okay, can I decrease the quantity?"
Okay, so instead of buying five, you buy
one, right? And then in terms of
quality, we go the other direction. So,
instead of buying this wood one, you buy
this metallic one. And if you're
starting with metallic, then maybe you
should go from this metal one to really
flimsy metal or an older model.
You should be able to apply this to
anything you sell. And once you've
mastered this, you can become a master
of increasing the lifetime value, aka
how much people spend with you. Imagine
this bucket is your business, and
imagine this is new customers coming in
the door.
If you don't fix this leaky bucket,
they're never going to be able to stack
up. And so,
once you fix it,
you can flow all as much as you want,
but now you're keeping your customers
and your revenue compounding. And if you
do that for a long enough period of
time, while we wait for my friend over
here to fill up the bucket, this is a
Cybertruck and this is a 100 grand. And
in the next 30 days, September, October,
November, December, each month in 2024,
I'm giving one of these to someone who's
watching this video right now. And so,
the way that you win this stuff is by
building the largest group on School
within the next month. And last month's
winner, just to give you some context,
got to about $50,000 per month in
recurring revenue. And we make it pretty
easy. So, right now, one out of two
people who starts a community on School,
that's paid, makes at least $1 online.
And often times, it's a lot more than
that. In fact, right now, the average is
$1,360
per month. So, no, this isn't going to
get you on the Forbes list, but it can
help get you started. And so, if that
sounds at all interesting, the best part
is you can start your own community on
School absolutely free going to
school.com/games.
All right? Join the community, have fun,
make money, save the world, and I'll see
you on the other side. And if you keep
doing it over time, you'll have more
money than you know what to do with. And
you'll be overflowing with customers and
cash. And that's how you create a cash
flow
explosion. And once you got people
buying and people are buying again and
again and again, now you're making a
little bit more money. But, the next
thing that you need is going to be help.
And so, you're going to have to have
other people help you along the way cuz
this is how you scale. And these are two
mannequins that represent employees. So,
let me share a framework with you that's
really expanded my vision in terms of
how companies grow. This has taken me
years to develop.
But, fundamentally, I see the size of a
company is always going to be limited by
the number of brains or the cumulative
knowledge that exists within the
company. And so, that should make some
sort of sense. Like, the amount of total
knowledge that that exists is going to
be the potential of the business. Which
is why as entrepreneurs, you have to
learn more because if you make your
brain bigger and you make your knowledge
base bigger, look how much bigger the
company can get. But, the thing is is
that you don't realize that you can get
three or four or five other people's
lives built into the business by saying,
"Hey, I don't need to learn finance. I'm
going to go find somebody who's got 20
years of finance experience in this
industry. Hey, I don't need to learn HR
and recruiting because I'm going to find
somebody who has that experience."
Because what happens is, once you do
that, the potential of the business
you can't even see it cuz the peak would
be all the way up here. And so, this is
the big unlock. This is how Steve Jobs
built the biggest, you know, one of the
biggest tech companies in the world. It
wasn't because he knew how to build the
iPhone. He knew how to build the team
that could build the iPhone. And so, the
most valuable skill set, fundamentally,
that you can have as a business owner is
the ability to get other people to do
stuff for you. And so, on one level, you
have the influence to get them to want
to do that thing for you. And then
everything else after that is enabling
them to know how to do the right stuff.
And so, the first is the persuasion
side. Now, that I think I covered during
the closer stuff. That's going to be the
values you have, what you represent, and
if people really admire you. And that's
where you have to continue to level up
yourself. This is the who you are part
in order to attract the best talent. But
once you have good talent, how do you
make sure that they know how to do the
right stuff? And so, I call this the
management diamond. All right? So, it's
very simple. So, I reverse this from if
somebody doesn't do what I want them to
do, why would that be? The first reason
is they didn't know that you wanted them
to do it at all because you hadn't told
them or you weren't clear about it. Now,
if they know that you wanted them to do
it, they might not have known
how to do it. Because they're like,
"Okay, I got that you wanted me to do
it, but I just don't know how." The
third is that they knew how they knew
that and how, but they didn't know when
you wanted them to do it by. So, they
could have just been totally able, they
just didn't know that you wanted it
right now. The next is they knew that,
how, and when, but they didn't have any
motivation to do it. They didn't know
why you wanted them to do it. And so,
when I think about each of these things,
you can actually solve this. So, you
solve this through coms. So, this is
through clear communication where you
include the deadlines, which is here,
what you solve for this one. Is that
whenever you include what you want
someone to do, you give them a time
duration, and then you ask them how long
they expect it's going to take. To solve
the how,
what we do is we have the three D's,
which is document, which is you figuring
out a checklist of exactly what you do.
Because often times when you're a
beginner or when you're starting your
own business, you have to do every
single job. And so you know how to do
the job better than they do. The problem
is in the beginning, you're more
unconsciously competent or you do a lot
of other things that you don't know that
you do, which is what makes you
successful. You're like, "No one can
sell like I can sell." What it really
means is I don't know how to teach
anyone like I can sell. And so that
means it's a deficit on you, not a
deficit on them. And so the first thing
you do is you document step-by-step
through a checklist what you do to get
the result, whether it's making a
website or it's doing outbound or doing
sales or making content, whatever it is,
you document step-by-step what you do.
The next is you demonstrate it, which
means you do it in front of them using
the document. So you say, "Hey, let me
show you how I'm following this
checklist, and then look at what
happens." So I follow the checklist and
look what happens. And they gain trust
in the checklist, in the documentation.
And so after you've documented and you
demonstrate in in front of them, then
they duplicate, which means they now do
it in front of you using the same
document. And if they get the same
outcome as you do using just the
document, then you have duplicated the
skill and now they can do it. And so
they know how. Now finally, the why is a
question of motivation.
So
I'm not going to be able to solve human
motivation in one video. But what I will
say is explaining and leveling up what
this thing does within an organization.
A lot of people do want to do a good job
and they do want to be contributing
members of society, but a lot of times
we haven't explained how what you do
here feeds this overall machine, which
hopefully does some good in the world.
And so it's simply explaining in simple
terms how customer service, for example,
it's like, "Hey, you do customer service
and you respond to tickets using this
process, we get happier customers.
Happier customers stay longer, pay more,
and refer their friends. And if we want
to have this big mission, one, we want
to make sure we're delivering to the
people that we're currently serving, but
on top of that, we want to be able to
help more people over time. And so, you
very much are important to our whole
business's success." And so, if every
person in the organization knows how
they tie what they do directly or
indirectly to you being successful as a
business, then they have a larger
motivation for why they should do it.
And so, if you ever have a conversation
where you're like, "Why is my employee
not doing anything?" I would also
suggest using this as a framework,
because then it's not None of these
blame them. You say, "Hey, John,
I asked you to do this, and then you
didn't do this.
And so, help me understand. Was it that
you didn't know that I wanted you to do
it? Cuz I see this message here, so was
that part unclear? Is it that you didn't
know how to do it? Was it that you
didn't know when to do it by? You didn't
know why to do it?" And let me give you
the bonus number five,
was there something blocking you?
And so, this is actually one of the most
common ones of the diamond, because what
it is is, for example, "Hey, I could
have the best chef in the world and I
say, 'Hey, make me an omelet.' He
understands what making an omelet is, he
knows how to do it, and I say, 'Make it
for me right now.' He's motivated cuz
he's on live television. What's the
problem?
He ain't got no eggs."
And so, the whole point is, and I had
this, I'll give you a real example. With
my team, I was like, "Hey guys, why are
you guys not getting these edits out on
time?"
And
they were like, "Ah, we want to spend
more time at home. We want to spend it
at the headquarters." And I was like, "I
built this massive headquarters for you
guys. Like, why are you not spending
time here?" And so, it turned out they
knew how to do it, they knew that I
wanted it, they knew when they needed it
by, they were very motivated to do it.
The problem was the internet at our
headquarters wasn't fast enough. They
were way faster at home. And so, we
spent 200 grand to get Google Fiber
drilled down into the building, so we
get a gigabyte a second now. And now,
they all edit here. And so, the thing
is, is a lot of times as a as a boss or
an owner, you have to see what are the
things that are blocking cuz most people
do want to do their jobs. But this
little five or five five-part framework,
this diamond, is one of the most
valuable tools I have because this
actually makes a productive discussion.
Cuz either you can solve the constraint
for them, or you find out that you've
got somebody who despite all of these
things still chooses not to do it, in
which case maybe it's not a good fit for
them. So we had a a new sales rep that
came in, uh and we were really excited
about him, and he you know he seemed
really sharp, really understood what was
going on. And within 3 days he was doing
all of the stuff, but he came to us and
was like,
"I really hate this."
Now, that's something that I can't fix.
If you hate, you know, talking to new
people and talking to customers or
talking to prospects all day long, then
sales is probably not for you. Now, that
being said, we also want to break down
like, "Hey, everything's got periods of
suck. You got to learn skills, things
like that." But if I check every one of
these boxes and someone says checks all
of them and nothing's stopping them
except for themselves, then it makes the
conversation really easy. It's like,
"Dude, I don't want you to do something
you don't want to do. No worries." So
boom, why do I bring a tripod here? If
you're like, "What are the three pillars
of the business?" These are the three
pillars of businesses Alex understands
them. The first, the tip of the spear,
is acquisition. That's marketing and
sales. That's letting people know about
your stuff and getting them to exchange
money in order to get it. The second
pillar is delivering that stuff. So
someone advertises, someone sells, and
then someone has to create and deliver
the iPhone. So once you advertise and
you sell, now you have to deliver the
product. You got to give the person the
iPhone. So that comes from the design,
that's product, that's distribution,
that's delivery. In service businesses,
that's customer success, that's
onboarding, that's delivering the
service itself. That is all the stuff
that goes into this delivery. It's how
you fulfill the promises that
acquisition made. The third one, and
this is the one that a lot of people
forget and this often limits businesses,
is operations. So this is everything
else that's not included in these two,
but that support these two. So think IT,
legal, finance, payroll, HR, recruiting.
All of that stuff supports these two
other functions. These are the core
value creators in the business. You got
to market and sell stuff, you got to
deliver that stuff. But everything else
that has to exist in order for these two
to continue to function. You got to pay
taxes, you got to pay payroll, you got
to send people checks, right? These are
all things that must exist, but most
entrepreneurs are severely lacking. And
this is sometimes where the biggest
outside help can come and help expand
the overall business so that the
potential of how big the thing is that
you want to build can get so much
bigger. And then you just keep adding
more and more people to this and you
keep expanding the stool. But the three
core pillars of the business remain
unchanged. And so if these are the three
pillars of the business and you want to
take a partner on. So let's say that I
want to take this partner, not
necessarily a life partner, but I want
to take a partner on in my business cuz
this happens a lot really early. And
usually it's because there's so much
work and you have no capital and you're
like, "Well, you know what? If two of us
work, at least twice as much stuff will
get done." The problem is most
partnerships come from two guys or two
gals who are buddies and say, "Hey,
let's get like we have fun hanging out
let's and we love talking about
business, let's do business together."
But the problem is let's say they both
love marketing and sales or they both
love product or they both love
operational stuff just like people and
things like that. Well, then you
actually are super top heavy and what
happens is
this goes like this cuz you're over over
indexed on one
and the tripod falls over. And so you
want to be balanced in the business so
that the business can continue to scale
proportionally across all functions. And
so if somebody is going to partner with
you, they have to have a skill that you
don't have, time you don't have, or
capital you don't have. And from the
skill perspective, it means they have to
have one of the other legs of the stool
that you don't have. From a capital
perspective, that might be the thing
that flows into the business that allows
these people to work in the beginning
when it might not be as profitable or
for you to buy inventory or for you to
buy a machine that you're going to do
the equipment with. Or, let's say it's
you sending the capital, somebody else
is going to be running the business on
your behalf as an operator owner. Now,
they're going to putting in time or
energy that you don't have cuz you're
doing other stuff. Congrats, you're now
done with level two. More money. And now
it's time to go to level three.
So, here we are on level three and I
want to quick take a quick pause to
invite you, if you're a business owner
doing over a million dollars a year and
you'd like to scale to the next level, I
want to invite you to come out to our
workshops here in Vegas to my
headquarters to meet with me and my
team, each of my functional directors
who are working with companies in my
portfolio doing hundreds of millions of
dollars a year to help you deconstraint
your business to get to the next level.
Whatever it is, if you're trying to go
from 1 million to 10 million or 10
million to 30 million or 50 million,
we've been to each of those levels
multiple times before and we know what
it looks like to have advertising go
from 1 to 10. We know what it looks like
to have delivery go from 10 to 30. We
know what it like looks like to have
finance go from 30 to 100. And so, we
can help you deconstraint those things
and help you ultimately scale. If that
sounds at all interesting, check out the
URLs around here and we'd love to have
you out. Otherwise, keep enjoying the
the vid. Let's go to the first level of
level three, keeping your advantage. So,
things are working, people are working
for you, you're making sales. Now, we
want to expand the gap between you and
everybody else. And if you're like, why
is there big seesaw here? I'll explain
in a second. But, the fundamental crux
of all this is the big word leverage,
which is let's define it.
How much you get for what you put in.
So, leverage doesn't mean good or bad,
it's just how much you get. Now, if I do
this many times and let's say I'm
pumping something, then I'm doing more
repetitions. And the amount of leverage
I get is proportional to the size of
this lever, right? Now, if I want to get
more for what I put in, then it means I
would extend this lever all the way out
here and I'd get more for every push. If
I wanted to have less, which why would
you, I would put my hands here and I
have a much smaller lever, so it's much
harder to do the same amount of work.
And so, how much you get is leverage.
High leverage is I get a lot for what I
put in. Low leverage is I get very
little for what I put in. And so,
there's lots of forms of leverage in a
business. And the idea is that you want
to have as many working for you at the
same time as humanly possible. So, I'll
give you a couple examples. So, one, one
that I've built mine on, is brand. It's
reputation. So, that means that if I
have a brand versus not having a brand,
the brand gives me leverage in a lot of
ways. So, number one is I have higher
click-through rates. If I run an ad with
a trusted figure, then more people will
click than otherwise would have normally
without a brand. That means I get more
for what I put in. High leverage.
Second,
I get higher conversion rates. And so,
the people who click also have a higher
likelihood of opting in, following
through, and ultimately buying.
And once people do that, then
they're able to say yes, or they're
willing to say yes, at higher prices.
Another form of leverage is people.
If I can get more for what I put in, I
only live one life's one lifespan, but I
can get somebody else's life, basically
their experience, to help propel my
business towards my goal, then I get my
life plus their life. And so, that gives
me
more leverage. So, I want to make this
real for you. So, imagine you see an
advertisement for this blank t-shirt.
All right? Are you inclined to buy it?
Probably not, unless you're just in the
market for white t-shirts. But all of a
sudden, if you see this one right next
to it, you might have a much higher
likelihood of clicking, converting, and
then buying at a higher price. So,
literally, if these are side by side,
this might be $30, and this might be $5,
and you still might be more likely to
buy this one. That is the leverage that
brand gets you. Because they, for the
same ad and the same dollars, get more
sales for what they put in. And you can
see leverage everywhere. If I write
code, and I write it one time, and then
millions of people use it, that gives me
leverage. I did work once, people use it
millions of times. So, for example, if I
write a book, then it takes me x amount
of time to write the book, but once the
book's written, I don't have to work
again for the book. But if people keep
telling their friends about the book and
saying it's good, then it continues to
sell copies and spread the word. That's
leverage. I'll give you another one. So,
if I get if I do this in the beginning,
I'm probably really inefficient at it.
But if I do this for days and days on
end, I probably realize I got to put my
weight on it. You know what I can lock
my arm out so I don't have to use my
muscles and I can just lower my weight
on this thing. So, my skill gets better
and so I get more per unit of effort.
And so, skill is also another form of
leverage. And so, one of the most
important relationships to get leverage
earlier on in your career is
understanding what work is. So, work,
which is what you do every day,
is volume
times leverage
equals
output.
Which means work
equals output. So, it's not about how
hard you work, it's about how much you
get for the work you do. And so, if I
have a lot of leverage, awesome, but if
I have a lot of leverage and I do a lot
of repetitions, then I get even more
output. And so, the thing is, and this
is what people don't understand, is in
the beginning you need to do volume
because volume gives you skill. Skill is
leverage. And so, for example, let's say
I'm doing cold calls in the beginning of
my career. If I do 100 cold calls and
somebody who's been doing cold calls for
10 years and has an amazing skill set
does 100 cold calls, he's going to get
more appointments booked than I will.
And so, for the same work, same volume,
he's going to get more output. So, in a
very real way, he worked more than I
did. He got more for what he put in. And
so, there is a reciprocal relationship
between volume and leverage because the
more you do, the better you get. And the
better you get, the more you like it.
The more you like it, the more you do
it. And so, this is the virtuous cycle
of work. But you have to get started in
the beginning when you have low
leverage. And so, the only thing you can
do is compensate with volume. It means
you have to do 1,000 door knocks, 1,000
cold calls, 1,000 cold emails, 1,000
pieces of content so that you can start
getting good. And so, one of my favorite
and least favorite sayings is work
smart, not hard because the reality of
it is that you have to work hard in
order to work smart. And so, now we just
finished keeping your advantage. So,
you've made even more money and you're
continuing to scale your business. And
so, now we move on to the next part of
level three, sticking with it. Because
if everything's going well, the only
thing that can stop you is you. And so,
I'll give you one of my favorite quotes
from Charlie Munger, which I'll
paraphrase. He more or less says,
"Compounding is the eighth wonder of the
world and the objective of compounding
is to never interrupt it." And so, he
talks about this to stop people from day
trading and getting people to buy in and
out of stocks. He says, "You should be
willing to buy a company and have the
stock market be closed for the next 5
years because you bought a share of a
company and you believe it's going to go
up for a long period of time. So, that's
why you buy high-quality businesses. But
the concept of not interrupting
compounding is one of the key
philosophies that I have around focus.
Focus is one of the most important
things of entrepreneurs. And if you talk
to the most successful entrepreneurs,
they talk about ruthlessly focusing for
long periods of time. And Steve Jobs was
famous for grilling his direct reports
and asking them when he would start
meetings, "What have you said no to
lately?" And so, I define focus by the
quality
and quantity of things you say no to.
So, if you say yes to many things, then
you are not focused. If you say no,
hypothetically, to literally everything
except for one thing, you would define
that person as incredibly focused,
probably obsessive. But like imagine a
kid, for example, who did nothing but
play video games all day. He's
incredibly focused on video games. He
doesn't eat, he doesn't sleep. I'm
saying hypothetically, he does nothing
else. He's incredibly focused. At some
point, I'm not saying you do that, but
it points out the hypothetical stream of
what focus really is. And so some people
claim to be focused, but it's not are
you focused or not, it's how focused are
you. And so if you followed any of my
stuff at all, I talk about the woman in
the red dress. And the reason I love
this analogy is it's perfect. So in the
Matrix, there's this moment, if you
haven't seen the movie, where Morpheus,
who's the guide or the teacher in the
story, is Neo, the main character, about
how the Matrix works. And so they're
walking through a crowded city, he's
talking about something, and he says,
"Were you looking Were you listening to
me, or you looking at the woman in the
red dress?" And he says, "What?" And he
says, "Look again." And he says, and
when he looks again, there's a gun
pointed at his head. And so he says, "If
you're not one of us, you're one of
them." And so these are agents. Agents
basically are the things that disrupt
everything in the system. And so what
appears to be a woman in the red dress,
what appears to be this shiny object,
this amazing thing that catches your
attention, this big opportunity you
think you should leave your current
thing for, that is often an agent in
disguise meant and sent to kill you and
destroy your progress and your focus.
But let me tell you how deceptive this
is, and this is what it looks like for
entrepreneurs. And so there's five
stages that I think entrepreneurs go
through. In the beginning, you have uh
zero, right? And then you have
uninformed
optimism, which means that you don't
know what you're talking about, but it
looks really good. This is the grass is
greener on the other side. Then
you have informed pessimism, which is
now that I got into it, oh, it actually
isn't that easy to make money in this
thing. Even though my cousin's doing it,
he's actually been doing it for 5 years,
and there's all these other things I
didn't know about. But now you know
about it, you're like, "Ooh, this is
actually a little harder than I
thought." Then, if you keep going, you
have the valley of despair. This is
where everyone gives up
and everyone stops trying. Now, what
happens most times is they never get to
step four.
What happens again, Well, I'll tell you
step four and then I'll tell you what
happens to us. So, step four is you get
to informed
optimism. So, now, remember the optimism
here? Now you're informed about it. So,
you're like, okay, I get
what it takes to make this work and I
can see a way for me to win. And then
finally, you get to here, which is you
achieve the goal, right? You do what you
set out to do to begin with. But you
have to go through the valley of
despair. This happens in every single
business, especially when you're
starting out. But what happens for most
entrepreneurs is
dotted line,
they start it all over again.
And so they say, oh, you know what? I'm
going to go find my point of uninformed
optimism because there's another thing.
It's not drop shipping, it's crypto.
It's not crypto, it's wholesaling. It's
not wholesaling, it's insert whatever
opportunity you think is quick and easy
and I promise you none of them are.
Because think about it this way, if
something were quick and easy, everyone
would do it and already be winning. So,
I'm going to break this myth in half
because I think it's so important
because it is the number one thing that
destroys most businesses is disrupting
compounding. And I think part of the
reason that this myth is proliferated is
because the people who are selling you
that myth make money on you buying their
solution. And so what they do is they
say, oh, the average millionaire has
seven income streams, right? And so you
think, oh, millionaires have seven
income streams, therefore I should have.
That's like saying, oh, the average
billionaire has a private jet, therefore
I should fly private to be a
billionaire. It confuses sequence. It's
not that you get tall when you play
basketball, it's that tall people play
basketball. And so for you in your
career, most people who make a lot of
money focus all of their eggs in one
basket and then once they've achieved
all this success, then they diversify.
But after they diversify, their returns
go down, not up. Bill Gates, for
example, if he had never sold his
Microsoft shares, right now would be a
trillionaire. He'd be worth 1 and 1/2
trillion today. Instead, he's worth 100
to 150 billion. And the main reason is
because he diversified after he focused
all of his wealth building into
Microsoft. Now, Steve Ballmer, his
number two man in the very beginning had
a much, much, much smaller share. So, I
think Ballmer has like 2 or 3% a tiny
slice of Microsoft. Bill Gates had 49%
when they went public. So, he had half
the company. And so, today Steve
Ballmer, his number two, is almost as
wealthy as Bill Gates.
Because he has stayed focused this whole
time and never liquidated his shares and
continued to grow Microsoft. And so,
they want to feed you this myth that
somehow 1/7 of you split between all
these things. They say, "Try a bunch of
stuff. See what works." The reality is
any of these things can work if you
concentrate all of your attention into
one. Then, see, overflows. Then,
that is how you get an overflowing
opportunity. You keep working it, you
keep doubling down on it, and you say no
to the woman in the red dress because
you know that she's just a valley of
despair. She's just an agent in
disguise. And if you stick with it, you
will win. And that's the thing that
separates the people who win from the
people who don't is that they can just
keep saying no to everything else. They
keep saying, "Yep, you know what? That's
an amazing opportunity for someone else.
That's an amazing opportunity for
someone else." And let me show you this
mathematically. So, let's say that
you're in your third month, your third
week, your third year, whatever
increment you want, of you developing
some skill, right? You continue to get a
little bit better every single year.
Fine. Now, you see this new opportunity
that you're ground zero for, and you
think, "Man, I think I could grow faster
by doing this thing." And so, you have
to reason, let's say that you're on year
four of opportunity number one, that
instead of saying, "Okay, well, I'm
going to go to you know, I'm going to go
to my fifth year." So, you're not you
haven't done this yet. So this is
hypothetical. Instead you say, you know
what? I'm going to start this new
opportunity. A new opportunity I'm going
to be here, which is higher than where I
was before and it's going to be a double
the rate. Okay, but now I'm on year two
here. Guess where I'm going to be if I'm
on year two past this on this
opportunity. And so you can't compare
year two here to year two here. You have
to compare year two here to year five
here.
And so this increment, I promise you,
it's significantly easier to take
something from $10 million to $15
million than it is to take from zero to
five in a year. So you finish keeping
your advantage and sticking with it and
you've made even more money. We just
keep making money. We're crazy.
And so we move on to the last and final
step of level three, get better and keep
getting better. And so one of the key
skills that I've developed over my
career that I want to share with you is
the ability to learn, but not in the way
that you might think traditionally. And
so what happens is sure, in the
beginning you want to get from courses
and experts and things like that, but
over time what you want to double down
on is volume. Because what volume does
is it gives you data and then data you
can do something called a common factors
analysis. So let's say that I make 10
pieces of content, okay? These are my 10
pieces of content. Hopefully that's 10.
All right. Now that means that within
those top 10 pieces those 10 pieces of
content, there's going to be a top one
and there's going to be a bottom one.
And this is going to be the one that did
better and this is going to be the one
that did the worst. And so what I want
to do is see what did the top 10% have
that this one didn't have? What are the
discrepancies between these two? And
those discrepancies are the golden
nuggets that build together to help you
acquire skills. And so one of the things
that people shy away from in the
beginning is how low leverage you are.
You have no capital, you have no
friends, you have no other people who
can help you. So it's just you and when
you start you suck. But the thing is is
that the pain of how bad it is and how
hard it is in the beginning is the thing
that forces you to seek out better ways
to do it. And so you have to go through
that pain so that you can seek out these
improvements and then all of a sudden
you figure out a new way to use that
lever that takes 1/10 the time. You
figure out how to tweak your email
headings to get way more open rates or
you tweak your offer to get way more
responses or you make your ad hooks
better so you get higher, you know,
people clicking the ad. All of those
things are skills. And so this pain and
this volume and this is the poor part,
getting a feedback loop going is what
creates skills. So it's not just doing a
lot. You have to do a lot so that you
can see what works so that you can get
better. Fundamentally, common factors
analysis is how I learn everything.
Because a lot of the skills that I have
to learn now are things that no one
teaches. There's no courses for what I
for what I'm trying to learn now. And so
I have to just try a lot of things and
see, "Huh, what do the top 10% have in
common?" And this works for figuring out
your customer avatar. You're like, "Hey,
what do my top 10% of customers, what do
they have in common in terms of what
they did and who they are? What are the
bottom 10%? What did they do and who are
they? Okay, well I want less of those
and more of these." And so this is a
continuous loop that you do on your
customers. The same thing works in your
content. the top 10 pieces and the
bottom 10 pieces? What are the top 10
ads and the bottom 10 ads? What are the
top 10 uh perfect sales scripts in terms
of recordings? What do we say
differently on those calls than we say
on these calls? It literally applies to
everything and that continuous loop of
progress and feedback is how you get
better and that is the core of leverage
from a skills perspective. And so right
now, if you're watching this video,
maybe a million dollars is your goal.
And if it is your goal, then you have to
deconstruct it to what you need to do.
Remember from the very beginning, and
what are the actions that I have to
take? And you take these actions so that
you can look at what worked and what
didn't so that you can get better. And
so this is fundamentally how you create
goals. And no, this isn't your mama's
goal video because you've already seen
that. This isn't about smart goals. This
is about your relationship with your
goals. And so this is something that I
don't see people talk about, but you
have a relationship with your goals. It
is something that you're willing to
sacrifice in order to keep. And so when
I think about this for myself, I had a
conversation with Leila for example,
where I said, "You know what? I define
love as what you're willing to give up
in order to keep something." And so you
say, "Hey man, that guy Rod, he must
love that car cuz he's he continues to
keep working on it over and over again,
it still doesn't work. He must love that
thing." Because of what he's willing to
put up in order to keep it. And so if we
think about that as the measuring stick
of how much not do I love something or
not, but how much do I love something,
then you can see in a very real way how
much do you really love your goals? Are
you willing to lose a friend over it?
Are you willing to give that up in order
to keep your goals? Are you willing to
give up a girlfriend for it in order to
keep your goals? Are you willing to give
up a wife or a spouse for it in order to
keep your goals? For me, the answer is
honestly yes. And the reason that I have
such an intimate relationship with my
goals, sounds kind of weird, is because
my goals have fed me more than anything
in my life. They have helped me become
the person that I want to be because
they have oriented my behavior to help
me do the activities that create the
character traits that create the
outcomes. And so I use that as my filter
for the people who are in my world. So
if someone comes in my world I think,
"Do I need to sacrifice my goals in
order to keep you?" Now a lot of times
it's not an all out sacrifice. Sometimes
I just ask the question, "Is my goal
achievement more or less likely with
this person in my life?" And often times
it's just neutral, which then for me is,
"Okay, well then you're going to drain
me of resources that don't get me to my
goals that I could otherwise, those
marbles, that I could otherwise keep
focused on the main thing." Which means
I have to say no to this because I
choose my goals over that. Now this may
sound extreme. And that's because it is.
But you can't want to be exceptional and
not be willing to be the exception. It
is normal to be not normal to have not
normal outcomes. If you can't expect
this is a preference thing from the
closes. You can't want my outcomes but
want it your way. If you change the
variables, you change the outcome. And
what I can tell you universally is that
the people who achieve outsized returns
are the ones who did outsized work and
more specifically made outsized
sacrifices in order to continue to be
able to pour in to that which mattered
most. And so I'll I'll be real with you
for a second. I've hit my million-dollar
goal. I hit my hundred-million-dollar
goal. And now I've been pretty public.
I'm trying to document everything that I
do to hit a billion and beyond. And
at the same time, the billion-dollar
goal matters a ton to me and at the same
time not at all. Because the
billion-dollar goal is not because I
want to hit a billion dollars for some
reason. I can't buy anything. There's
nothing I can buy at a billion that I
can't really buy now that would that I
can consume as an individual. Sure,
maybe I'll buy companies or buy big
buildings or something like that. But it
doesn't actually change my day-to-day
living. But the reason that I hold on to
that billion-dollar goal is because I
would like to meet the man who I would
become
who's able to achieve that. And so for
me, the quantitative measure of what my
business has grown has been an indicator
of my personal growth. And so I have a
belief that either your business is
growing or you are.
And so when your business is going is
going down, guess what? You're usually
growing a ton cuz it's painful. And
that's why they call it growing pains,
not growing joys.
It's not fun. But the thing is is that
most things in life aren't fun. Decline
is painful. Stagnation is painful.
Growth is painful. The question is which
of those pains get you closer to where
you want to go? Follow the steps in this
video and hit your million. But you
should want to make as soon as you hit
the million, set it for 10. And as soon
as you had 10, set it for 100. Not
because you need the money, because but
because you want to meet the man or
woman who's capable of making that a
reality.
The biggest gains in life, the best
players in life, play infinite games
because the objective isn't to win.
You're not going to win at business.
Like take it to the natural stream.
Let's say you become the richest man in
the world. Let's look historically at
the richest men. None of them was the
richest man for their entire lives. They
touched the top for a brief second, for
a year, for 2 years, and then they
disappear or they die. So, it's this
whole idea that's not even true. You
don't win.
The point of business is to stay in
business. That is why it's an infinite
game. The point of marriage is not to
get married, it's to stay married. The
point of fitness and health isn't to get
fit or get healthy, it's to stay
healthy. And so, most of the games worth
playing in life are not finite games,
they're infinite. And so, if you can
adopt this learning mentality, then
there is no end because you
are the asset. You are the outcome. And
so, by saying that you are finished
playing means that you are finished
becoming.
And for me, I don't want to stop getting
better until the day I die. So, we
started your journey to your first
million by figuring out what skills you
needed to have, what knowledge you
needed to know to get started. Then,
figured out who you were going to sell
to. Then, what you were going to sell
them. Then, figured out how to advertise
and close in order to get them to buy.
Then, from there, we increased how much
they were worth by getting them to buy
more times. Then, we recruited the
people who needed to be on our team to
help us along the way and scale. Then,
we keep and expand our advantage through
leverage. And we stick with it to unlock
compound and growth within the business
and ourselves. And then finally, we get
better through a continuous learning
loop. And that is how you get to first
million. And if you enjoyed this, click
the next video, which is 13 years of
brutally honest business advice because
at this point, hopefully you'll have
your first million or be on the way to
it, and then I'm going to hit you with
some harsh truths of getting from one to
10 and beyond.